Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Often in the theatre, in the full view of the people, Theodora would throw off her clothes and stand naked in their midst, having only a pair of knickers over her private parts and her groin,
感谢收听《历史余音》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告干扰音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史余音》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告音频以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。西奥多拉常常在剧院里，在众目睽睽之下，脱下衣服，赤身裸体地站在人群中央，只有下体和腹股沟处遮着一件短裤，
not because she was ashamed to expose these also to the public, but because no one is allowed to appear there absolutely naked. Underwear is compulsory. And with this costume, she would spread herself out and lie on her back on the floor. Certain menials on whom this task had been imposed would then sprinkle barley grains over her private parts, and geese trained for the purpose used to pick them off with their beaks one by one and swallow them. Theodora, far from blushing when she stood up again, actually seemed to be proud of this performance, for she was not only shameless herself, but did more than anyone else to encourage shamelessness. And many times she threw off her
倒不是因为她羞于向公众展示这些部位，而是因为那里不允许任何人一丝不挂。内衣是强制要求的。穿着这身行装，她会舒展身体，仰面躺在地板上。一些被指派了这项任务的仆从随后会把大麦粒撒在她的隐私部位上，专门为此训练的鹅会用喙一颗一颗地把大麦粒啄下来并吞掉。西奥多拉重新站起来时，非但没有脸红，反而对这场表演感到骄傲，因为她不仅自己不知羞耻，而且比任何人都更积极地助长这种厚颜无耻之风。她曾多次脱下
clothes and stood in the middle of the actors on the stage, leaning over backwards or pushing out her rear to invite both those who had already enjoyed her and those who had not been intimate as yet, parading her own special brand of gymnastics. With such lasciviousness did she misuse her own body that she appeared to have her privates, not like other women in the place intended by nature, but in her face. That, Dominic, was Procopius, a historian from Palestine in the 6th century, writing about indisputably the most famous of all the empresses of Constantinople, Theodora. And it is one of the most notorious, scabrous, shocking passages in the whole of ancient literature. Yes, it is, Tom. Her own special brand of gymnastics.
衣服，站在舞台上的演员中间，向后弯腰或向前挺起臀部，以此来挑逗那些已经享受过她的人以及尚未与她亲密接触过的人，大肆炫耀她那套特技般的体操。她以如此纵欲的方式糟践自己的身体，以至于人们觉得她的私密部位不在其他女人身上自然长有的地方，而是长在脸上。多米尼克，这段文字出自普罗科皮乌斯——一位来自6世纪巴勒斯坦的历史学家，他所写的内容正是关于君士坦丁堡所有皇后中无疑最著名的一位：西奥多拉。这是整个古代文学中最声名狼藉、最粗俗、最令人震惊的段落之一。没错，汤姆，确实如此。她那套特技般的体操。
That's a phrase that I think a lot of our listeners will take with them from this podcast. Yes. And so the huge question that hangs over that is, how is it that the most famous empress of Constantinople could have such filth? I think you can call it filth. I think you can call it filth. I think you can. Sexist filth indeed, Tom. Written about her.
这句话我想很多听众听完这期播客后都会印象深刻。是的。因此，悬在这一问题上方巨大的疑问是：君士坦丁堡最著名的皇后怎么会有如此下流的言论？我想你可以称之为下流。我觉得你完全可以称之为下流。我想你确实可以。这确实是充满性别歧视的下流言论，汤姆。竟然是关于她的记载。
Is it true? And what is the context for this extraordinary passage? Well, Tom, let us remember one thing. The woman we're talking about here is a saint. It's literally a saint. So that is a further dimension. A further complication. So Theodora and her husband Justinian are probably the two most famous,
这是真的吗？这段非凡的文字背后的历史背景是什么？好吧，汤姆，让我们记住一件事。我们在这里讨论的这个女人是一位圣人。字面意义上的圣人。所以这又是一个新的维度，又一个复杂的层面。因此，西奥多拉和她的丈夫查士丁尼可能是
most celebrated individuals associated with what we now think of as the Byzantine Empire. Although, Tom, that's not a label that they ever used of themselves. They're the Romans. They were the Romans. So this is the glamour, the decadence, the so-called decadence, the exoticism to Western observers of the Eastern Roman Empire, of the successor. Well, is it a successor state? We can talk about that in the podcast.
与我们现在所知的拜占庭帝国联系最为紧密的两个最著名、最显赫的人物。不过，汤姆，这并不是他们自己使用过的标签。他们是罗马人。他们就是罗马人。所以，这就是西方观察家眼中东罗马帝国、继承者的魅力、颓废（所谓的颓废）以及异国情调。等等，这是一个继承国吗？我们可以在播客中讨论这个。
Of this empire that from, let's say, what would you say, Tom? The 4th century to the 15th century dominates the Eastern Mediterranean. It's the world of icons, of mosaics, of magnificent churches, of Constantinople, the greatest city on earth. The empire that is seen by some historians today as the sort of the shield of Europe against Islam. But it's actually not as well known, I in the west as it should be would you agree with that tom well this is this is a topic both of us have really wanted to do so i've written a book about this in the shadow of the sword just get my plug in and um you are wearing a t-shirt with the emblem of byzantium on the front i am by coincidence i'm not wearing it deliberately for
这个帝国从——比如说，汤姆，你会怎么说？——公元4世纪一直统治到15世纪，支配着整个东地中海。这是圣像、马赛克、宏伟教堂的世界，是君士坦丁堡这个地球上最伟大城市的世界。这个帝国在今天的某些历史学家看来，是欧洲抵御伊斯兰教的一道盾牌。但在西方，它其实不像它本该拥有的那样广为人知，汤姆，你同意这一点吗？嗯，这是我们俩一直都非常想做的一个主题——为此我写过一本关于这方面的书《剑影之下》（顺便打个广告），而且呢，你身上正穿着一件印有拜占庭徽标的T恤。我确实穿着，纯属巧合，我不是故意为了
this oh i thought because i've always been an aficionado of this because i studied it at university and um and funnily enough the reason i studied at university was the first thing i did when i went to oxford and it was because it was so it seemed to me you know i was 18 and it seemed so exotic and glamorous compared with the english civil war which i've been doing for a level and i think to most people byzantium still has that allure doesn't it it's the sort of golden horn yes the very um the very language so um john the lydian um historian another historian byzantine historian described constantinople as the all golden city and it's that idea of gold isn't it and it's that idea i mean some some people will be familiar with this because we did a podcast about the vikings in the east and the idea of the vikings sailing down all these
这个节目才穿的。哦，我还以为——因为我一直对这段历史情有独钟，我在大学里研究过它，而且说来也巧，我大学时研究它的原因，正是我去牛津后做的第一件事，因为当时我觉得它太……我当时18岁，比起我A-Level考过、因而早已熟知的英国内战，它显得那么异国情调，那么光芒四射。我想对大多数人来说，拜占庭仍然有着那种吸引力，对吧？那种金角湾的感觉。是的，那种极其……那种语言本身……比如，历史学家约翰·利迪乌斯——又一位拜占庭历史学家，将君士坦丁堡描述为“全金之城”，正是那种对黄金的想象，对吧？这种想象——有些人可能会觉得熟悉，因为我们之前做过一期关于维京人东征的播客，维京人顺着所有这些
rivers and into the black sea and at the end they see this golden city that is basically the template for asgard this world of a harbor full of ships massive city walls the churches the dome of the hagia sophia the church of thedom, like nothing they had ever seen on earth. Caesar's golden city. Yeah. I mean, it just has an incredible resonance and romance. So I think probably the best way to start on this story, and I think we should come to the question of how accurate that portrayal of the Taurus youth may have been. And also we should say that Procopius is equally as rude about Justinian. He is indeed. We shall become to Justinian's face later in the podcast.
河流驶入黑海，最后他们看到了那座金色的城市，这基本上就是阿斯加德（Asgard）的原型，一个港口停满船只、城墙巨大、到处都是教堂的世界，圣索菲亚大教堂的穹顶，见所未见，空前绝后。恺撒的金城。对啊。我的意思是，它具有令人难以置信的情感共鸣和浪漫色彩。所以我想，开始讲述这个故事最好的切入点，或许我们应该探讨一下对陶尔斯青年（Taurus youth）的这种描绘到底有多准确。而且我们还得说，普罗科皮乌斯对查士丁尼也同样毫不客气。他的确如此。我们稍后会在播客中聊到查士丁尼的长相。
So he's not just being sexist when he's rude. I mean, he's rude about everybody. Yeah. But I think to begin with, it would make sense, wouldn't it, to look at Constantinople, the city that is the stage for both these extraordinary figures. And you talked about how this is described as the capital of the Byzantine Empire, but you also then immediately said, well, yes, but it's the Roman Empire as well.
所以他在刻薄时并不只是针对女性。我的意思是，他对所有人都很刻薄。是的。不过我想首先，探讨一下君士坦丁堡——这座作为这两位非凡人物舞台的城市，是非常合乎逻辑的，对吧？你刚才谈到这座城市如何被称为拜占庭帝国的首都，但紧接着你又说，是的，但它同时也是罗马帝国。
So we should probably just kind of focus in on the degree to which what we call the Byzantine Empire is a break from the Roman Empire and not. And I would say it isn't really. Yeah, I agree with you completely because the key thing about constantinople is it is it is strategically it's incredibly defensible so it's a kind of promontory sticking out from thrace sticking out from the kind of the easternmost section of europe that means that if you build walls around it it's very easy to defend but it's also, it controls what already by the second century are the two key areas for Roman strategists, namely the Danube and the frontier with the Syrian frontier. So I'm writing about Hadrian at the moment. And when he becomes emperor, he's facing war both
所以我们或许应该聚焦于这样一个问题：我们所说的拜占庭帝国在多大程度上是对罗马帝国的延续，又在多大程度上算是一种断裂。而我要说的是，它其实算不上断裂。是的，我完全同意你的看法，因为君士坦丁堡最关键的特征在于，从战略上看，它具有无与伦比的防御能力——它就像是一个从色雷斯（Thrace）凸显出来的岬角，凸显在欧洲最东端的区域。这意味着如果你在它周围修建城墙，防守将易如反掌；与此同时，它也控制着早在公元2世纪就已经成为罗马战略家最看重的两个关键区域，即多瑙河沿岸和叙利亚边境。我目前正在写关于哈德良的书。当他成为皇帝时，他面临着来自
on the Syrian frontier and on the Danube. And so the first winter that he spends as emperor, he spends probably in Byzantium, which is the original Greek name of the city. So even then you can see that the fact that this is a position from which you can control these kind of two frontiers makes it absolutely key. And really the question is why it wasn't bigger. I think one of the reasons why it wasn't bigger and more strategic before it kind of gets promoted to become the second rome the new rome is is the lack of water um it's as basic as that yeah but once you sort that out so once you've got aqueducts these tremendous aqueducts bringing water to the city i mean as you say i think the position is so you can go to the the bosphorus obviously most people will have heard of the bosphorus the waterway the strait
叙利亚边境和多瑙河的双线作战。因此，他作为皇帝度过的第一个冬天，很可能是拜占庭度过的——拜占庭是这座城市最初的希腊语名字。所以即便在那个时候你也能看出，这个能够掌控这两大边境的位置是何等至关重要。真正的问题在于，它为什么没有变得更大。我认为它之所以在被提拔为“第二罗马”、“新罗马”之前没有变得更大、更具战略意义，原因之一就是缺水。事情就是这么基础。但一旦你解决了这个问题——一旦你有了引水渠，这些将水运送到城市的宏伟引水渠，正如你所说，这里的地理位置极其优越，你可以前往博斯普鲁斯海峡，显然大多数人都听说过博斯普鲁斯海峡，这条水道和海峡
that divides europe from Asia. You've got the Sea of Marmara. And once you go down through that, you're into the Aegean. So the strategic location is perfect. And I think if you think about the Roman Empire, so obviously Rome, the city of Rome, still has this tremendous sort of prestige. But all the action has been taking place on the frontiers for the Romans by the fourth century, I suppose. And they've been moving around, haven't they, the emperors? They've spent time in Milan.
将欧洲和亚洲分隔开来。你拥有马尔马拉海。一旦穿过它，你就进入了爱琴海。所以这里的战略位置堪称完美。如果你回想一下罗马帝国，显而易见，罗马城本身仍然享有那种巨大的声望；但对公元4世纪的罗马人来说，所有的行动重心其实都已经转移到了边境地区。皇帝们也一直在四处迁徙，不是吗？他们曾在米兰居住过。
They're military emperors who need to be close to the frontiers to deal with the action on the frontiers, which is the kind of, in inverted commas, barbarian incursions. And Constantinople makes sense as you say because actually we we often because we're so western orientated we forget that for the romans the big rival was always the same wasn't it was persia yeah and that frontier in mesopotamia is of all the frontiers i suppose that's the high value one the prestigious because a victory against the persians is more valuable in in pr terms than a victory against gothians is more valuable in PR terms than a victory against Goths or something. Because back in Hadrian's day, he's facing the Parthians who are a kind of shadowy threat compared to the Persian, the Sasanian empire that emerges in the third century and which kind of endures throughout this period. And effectively, it's a rival superpower, which the Romans hadn't previously had to face. And so that I think is really the key to why the city of Byzantium in the early fourth century becomes the city of
他们是军事皇帝，必须离边境近一些，以便应对边境上的冲突——也就是加了引号的“蛮族入侵”。正如你所说，君士坦丁堡之所以合理，是因为我们常常由于视角过于西方化，而忘记了对罗马人而言，最大的死敌其实一直是那个老对手，对吧？那就是波斯。是的。美索不达米亚的那个边境，在所有的边境中——我想那是价值最高、最负盛名的边境，因为战胜波斯在公关（PR）方面的价值，要高于战胜哥特人什么的。因为早在哈德良时期，他面对的是帕提亚人，与三世纪崛起并在这一时期始终延续的波斯萨珊王朝相比，帕提亚人只是一种隐蔽的威胁。实际上，这是一个罗马人此前从未不得不面对的超级大国竞争对手。所以我想这才是公元4世纪初拜占庭城变成
Constantinople. Constantinople. Constantine has defeated all his rivals for the rule of the empire. He's the sole ruler. And just as he is the sole ruler on earth, so he has enshrined as the prevailing deity over the Roman Empire, the Christian God who rules alone over the universe, the cosmos. And he wants a new capital. And I think that that is what makes Constantinople different to say Milan or Trier or any of these other kind of places that have been temporary capitals, is that Constantine deliberately sets out to make it a second Rome, a new Rome. But what's so interesting about Constantinople, though, isn't it, Thomas, that it is the duality. So it's both a new Rome, and at first they have lots of statues of Romans,
君士坦丁堡的关键所在。君士坦丁堡。君士坦丁击败了所有争夺帝国统治权的竞争对手。他成为了唯一的统治者。正如他是大地上唯一的统治者一样，他将基督教的上帝——这位独自统治宇宙、世界万物的上帝——确立为凌驾于罗马帝国之上的至高神明。他想要一座新首都。我认为这正是君士坦丁堡与米兰、特里尔或任何其他曾充当过临时首都的地方不同的地方：君士坦丁是有意将其打造成第二罗马、新罗马。然而，汤姆，君士坦丁堡最有趣的地方难道不是它的两面性吗？它既是一座新罗马，起初那里有许多罗马人的雕塑，
don't they? They do it in that kind of classical style. But at the same time, it quickly becomes a sort of rival centre of Christendom to Rome itself, doesn't it? And that's really important because it gives it a different character from Rome, which I suppose to some people might seem tainted by the paganism of the past. To a degree. But I think that when Constantine founds Constantinople, and right the way up to the time of Justinian in the early 6th century, the patterns that Constantinople has inherited from Rome are really important. So obviously, you have the figure of the emperor and his palace. And initially, Constantine, it's modeled on a praetorium, so a kind of military headquarters, but it rapidly becomes much, much larger than that, this kind of great sprawling edifice. Then you have a Senate, and then you have the masses of the people. And just as in Rome, the emperor meets the people in the Circus Maximus, which is the great chariot racing space.
不是吗？他们采用了那种古典风格。但与此同时，它又迅速演变成了一个与罗马本身分庭抗礼的基督教中心，对吧？这非常重要，因为它赋予了它一种不同于罗马的特质——在某些人看来，罗马或许已被过去的异教风气所玷污。在某种程度上确实如此。不过我认为，当君士坦丁建立君士坦丁堡时，一直到6世纪初查士丁尼统治时期，君士坦丁堡从罗马继承下来的各种体制框架都极其重要。显然，你拥有皇帝及其宫殿的形象。最初，君士坦丁是以禁卫军司令部（praetorium）——一种军事指挥总部为蓝本建造的，但它很快就变得大得多，变成了一种庞大而错综复杂的建筑群。接着你有了元老院，然后是广大民众。就像在罗马一样，皇帝在马克西穆斯竞技场（Circus Maximus）——那个巨大的战车赛场上与民众会面；
So in Constantinople, you have this space, the Hippodrome, where chariots race. And so that idea of a kind of tripartite division of the emperor, the Senate, the people is something that Constantinople inherits. And I think that there's a kind of, people in Constantinople feel the kind of anxiety of Parvenus in the early years, which is why Constantine, basically, I mean, he does a Lord Elgin. He just goes around, you know, the great cities ofantine, basically, I mean, he does a Lord Elgin. He just goes around, you know, the great cities of Greece, stripping them of all their treasures and dumping them in Constantinople. So there's this great bath complex there, the Baths of Zypos, which are absolutely adorned with, you know, it's kind of like the British Museum.
因此在君士坦丁堡，你也拥有这样一个空间：赛马场（Hippodrome），战车在那里竞速。所以君士坦丁堡继承了这种皇帝、元老院、民众的三权分立的理念。而且我认为，君士坦丁堡的人民在早期有一种暴发户般的焦虑感，这就是为什么君士坦丁基本上——我的意思是，他搞了一次“埃尔金大理石”（Lord Elgin）式的掠夺。他四处奔走，去到希腊的各大城市，剥夺它们所有的宝藏，并将它们倾倒在君士坦丁堡。所以那里有一个巨大的浴场综合体——齐波斯浴场（Baths of Zeuxippus），里面装满了各种珍宝，简直就像英国博物馆一样。
It's absolutely stuffed full of loot. So I think that that matters. And they, and topographers kind of, you know, they rustle up seven hills in Constantinople. I'm just looking at a map now with these seven hills that by a remarkable coincidence, same number as in Rome. Yeah. And Rome had always been the city that grain comes from Egypt and North Africa and Constantinople has that kind of grain as well. So you have all these kinds of elements that are very, very deliberately modelled on Rome. I mean, I'm just looking at a map of Constantinople in the 6th century. Now,
里面塞满了战利品。所以我觉得这很重要。而且他们——地形学家们也煞费苦心地在君士坦丁堡凑出了七座山丘。我正看着一张地图，上面标着这七座山丘，由于一种非巧合的奇迹，数量和罗马的一模一样。是的。罗马一直是一座粮食来自埃及和北非的城市，君士坦丁堡也拥有那种粮食供应。所以你拥有所有这些刻意模仿罗马的元素。我的意思是，我正在看一张6世纪君士坦丁堡的地图。现在，
you can download them from the internet. And to just pick up on what you were saying, I mean, the Hippodrome is right by the palace complex. It actually reminds me in some ways, Tom, of something we did talked about in a previous podcast, Ptolemaic Alexandria, of a city that is both a city of great learning and sort of a city of scholarship and sort of seriousness and stuff. And yet there's always that mob. You know, there's that sort of. And the fact that the palace and the hippodrome are so close together. So to give people who don't know much about this a sort of sense of it. This is Istanbul.
你可以从互联网上下载它们。顺着你刚才的话说，赛马场紧挨着宫殿建筑群。这其实在某些方面让我想起了一点，汤姆，我们在之前的播客中讨论过的话题：托勒密时期的亚历山大港——那是一座既充满伟大学识、学术氛围和严肃气息的城市，然而却总是少不了暴民的存在。你知道，那种……而且宫殿和赛马场挨得如此之近。为了让不太了解这一背景的人有一种直观的感受：这就是伊斯坦布尔。
It's modern Istanbul. It's the part of Istanbul called Fatih.anbul it's modern istanbul it's the part of istanbul called fatty so it's on the european side it's on the southern side of the of the harbor known as the golden horn and i mean constantinople grows so quickly doesn't it tom so by the time we're talking about it's probably got what half a million people yeah but half a million probably the biggest city in the world i think i mean maybe chinese historians might dispute that but i think it's most people would say it's probably the big single biggest city in the world the measure of that is that constantine has built walls and they've rapidly kind of grown out of them so um in the um in the fifth century an empirical theodosis
它是现代的伊斯坦布尔。它是伊斯坦布尔被称为法提赫（Fatih）的地区。它位于欧洲一侧，位于被称为金角湾（Golden Horn）的海港南侧。我的意思是，君士坦丁堡发展得如此之快，对吧，汤姆？所以到我们讨论的这个时期，它大概有多少人口？五十万左右。差不多有五十万，可能是世界上最大的一座城市，我想——也许中国历史学家会有所异议，但我想大多数人都会说它可能是当时绝对世界第一大城市。衡量这一点的标准是，君士坦丁修建了城墙，而城市却迅速扩张，超出了城墙的范围；因此，在
second builds another vastly imposing sequence of walls that are further out. And so essentially, the stretch of land between Constantine's walls and Theodosius' walls are where cisterns can be built to store water. There are monasteries, there are kind of market gardens. They're the walls that you see today, by the way, the Theodosians. They're still standing. I mean, they're incredible. And they're the walls that you see today by the way the theaters they're still standing i mean they're fast and i think there's a case for saying that they are probably the best infrastructure investment of all time because they enable constantinople to withstand any number of
5世纪时，皇帝狄奥多西二世又修建了一道极为雄伟的新城墙，位置更加靠外。所以本质上，君士坦丁的城墙和狄奥多西的城墙之间的那片狭长地带，就是用来建造蓄水池以储存水的地方，那里有修道院，有菜园。顺便说一句，今天你看到的城墙就是狄奥多西时期的。它们依然屹立不倒。我的意思是，它们太不可思议了。顺便说一句，今天你看到的城墙就是狄奥多西时期的。它们依然屹立不倒。我的意思是，太壮观了。而且我认为有充分的理由认为，它们可能是史上最佳的基础设施投资，因为它们使君士坦丁堡能够经受住无数次
sieges um and they're built with the you know all the resources that rome then had and a hugely beneficial investment. Well, I think that's a really important point, Tom, because the portrait ever since Edward Gibbon wrote his Decline and Fall of the Roman Empire, the image we've had of this world in English speaking countries has been one of a sort of sad decline from the virtues of the Roman heyday, and a sort of decadence. So in other words, you'll have a sort of a book on the Roman Empire in which they'll cover 500 years in 400 pages and then another thousand years in 10 pages. Oh, this was a sad epilogue and it's all very decadent and orgiastic. And of course, the end was coming. The writing was on the wall basically when they founded
围攻，而且它们的修建动用了罗马当时拥有的所有资源，这是一笔收益巨大的投资。嗯，我认为这是一个非常关键的观点，汤姆，因为自从爱德华·吉本（Edward Gibbon）写了《罗马帝国衰亡史》以来，英语国家对这个世界的印象一直是：它标志着罗马全盛时期美德的悲哀衰落，以及某种颓废。换句话说，你会看到一本关于罗马帝国的书，它用400页的篇幅涵盖了500年的历史，然后用区区10页的篇幅讲完了剩下的一千年。哦，这只是一个悲伤的尾声，一切都非常颓废，充满了酒神狂欢。当然，结局早已注定。当他们建立
Constantinople. But obviously, that's a ludicrous way of looking at it. I mean, this is a city that endures for the best part of a thousand years until it's taken by the Fourth Crusade. Is it the Fourth Crusade? It is the Fourth Crusade, isn't it? And then later on, the Ottomans. I mean, this is a very, very rich, sophisticated... I mean, as we said, the biggest city on earth, incredibly multicultural, cosmopolitan. You would have heard in the marketplaces every imaginable language i mean obviously it's a very christian city but there must have been visitors from every part of the known world um you could buy anything you wanted it's a city of pleasure it's a it's got these kind of seething crowds in the hippodrome i mean an incredibly intoxicating place and i think also
君士坦丁堡时，墙上的字就已经写好了。但很显然，这种看法荒谬绝伦。我的意思是，这是一座延续了近千年之久、直到被第四次十字军东征攻陷的城市。是第四次十字军东征吗？的确是第四次十字军东征，对吧？后来又是奥斯曼人。我的意思是，这是一个非常非常富有、高度精致的……正如我们所说，这是地球上最大的城市，极其多元文化，充满大都会气息。你在集市上可以听到你能想象到的各种语言。虽然它显然是一座极其虔诚的基督教城市，但也必然有来自已知世界各个角落的访客。你可以买到任何你想要的东西。这是一座充满享乐的城市，赛马场里人头攒动，沸腾喧嚣——我的意思是，这是一个极其令人陶醉的地方。而且我认为，
part of the reason why whybon and why, you know, the word Byzantine has become such a kind of pejorative is because there's a feeling that the less Roman it becomes, the more it goes into decline. But I don't think, I mean, I don't think that's true at all. I mean, the elements of the Roman remain, and I think they are very radically recalibrated under Justinian in paradoxical ways. And in many ways, Justinian's reign is both an attempt to restore the Roman Empire and a complete recalibration of it. And it does end up becoming a Greek empire, a Christian empire. The Roman and the pagan elements tend to, you know, fade away. But the kind of the richness of that means that it is an astonishingly sophisticated and fascinating civilization. And Justinian and Theodora play key, key roles.
吉本之所以持这种观点，以及“拜占庭”这个词为什么会变成一个贬义词，部分原因在于人们有一种感觉：它变得越不罗马化，就越走向衰落。但我不认为——我的意思是，我不认为这有任何真实性。罗马的元素依然存在，而且我认为在查士丁尼统治下，它们以一种自相矛盾的方式被彻底重新校准了。在很多方面，查士丁尼的统治既是一次恢复罗马帝国的尝试，也是对罗马帝国的一次彻底重新校准。它最终确实变成了一个希腊帝国的、基督教的帝国。罗马元素和异教元素往往……你知道，逐渐淡出了。但那种丰富性意味着它是一个令人惊叹的、高度精致且引人入胜的文明。查士丁尼和西奥多拉在其中扮演了关键至关重要的角色。
Just before we get on to Justinian and Theodora, just one last thing about the geopolitics of it. Because obviously, the Roman Empire has changed since it's what we commonly think of as its heyday but the bits that have been as it were lost i mean they are the bits you would actually if you had to lose but including rome they are the bits you would you would choose to lose because they're poorer so you would choose to lose britain and if you had to you would get rid of gaul okay fine you you'd prefer to keep Spain, but if you have to lose it, you do. Because the bits that are left are not some sort of decadent leftover.
在我们谈到查士丁尼和西奥多拉之前，关于它的地缘政治还有最后一件事要说。因为很明显，自我们通常认为的全盛时期以来，罗马帝国已经发生了变化，但那些被“失去”的部分——我的意思是，它们其实正是你如果必须失去的话也愿意失去的部分。包括罗马在内，它们正是你愿意主动放弃的部分，因为它们较为贫穷。所以你愿意失去不列颠，如果必须的话，你也会摆脱高尔，好吧，没问题，你或许更愿意保留西班牙，但如果你不得不失去它，你也会这么做。因为剩下的部分并不是某种颓废的残羹冷炙。
They are the richest, most productive, you know, they're the most interesting, most potent bits, aren't they? So it's basically the half that Mark Antony had when he and Octavian divided up the empire. It's exactly that half. It is, and that reflects the fact that there are kind of geographical factors in the split between the West and the Eastern halves. And the Western half that gets conquered by
它们是最富饶、最具生产力、你知道的，它们是最有趣、最有潜力的部分，对吧？所以它基本上就是马克·安东尼和屋大维瓜分帝国时，安东尼分到的那一半。完全就是那一半。确实如此，这反映出一个事实：东西两半的裂痕背后有着地理因素。被
the barbarians, as the Romans would call them, they drift away because of the fact you have the Alps, you have the Adriatic, you know, these are kind of natural barriers and borders. But having said that, you know, if you had to give up anything, you'd give up the Western half. There are two obvious areas that people in Constantinople are particularly keen to get back. One is North Africa, which is incredibly rich as a supplier of grain. So that really matters. And the other, of course, is Italy, because Italy has the original Rome. Just to fill people in, Tom, to the Vandals in North Africa.
罗马人称为蛮族的蛮族征服的西方半壁，由于阿尔卑斯山、亚得里亚海的存在——这些是天然的屏障和边界——而逐渐漂离了出去。话虽如此，你知道，如果你必须放弃什么，你会放弃西方半壁。君士坦丁堡的人民特别渴望收复两个显而易见的区域。一个是北非，作为粮食供应地，它极其富饶。所以这非常重要。另一个当然是意大利，因为意大利拥有最初的罗马。为了让大家了解情况，汤姆，落入北非汪达尔人手中的——
So that's, when we say North Africa, we're talking about the coasts of Algeria, Libya, Tunisia. And then Italy has fallen to the Goths, hasn't it? Yeah, the Ostrogoths. And this matters not just because the loss of the original Rome is a humiliation, but also because in a Christian world, the Pope, the Bishop of Rome, remains the senior bishop. Even though the patriarch, the Bishop of Constantinople, has been kind of promoted over the heads of the bishops of Antioch and Jerusalem and Alexandria.
所以，当我们说北非时，我们指的是阿尔及利亚、利比亚、突尼斯的海岸。然后意大利落入了哥特人手中，对吧？对，东哥特人。这之所以重要，不仅是因为失去最初的罗马是一种羞辱，还因为在一个基督教世界里，教皇——罗马主教，依然是资深的主教。尽管牧首——君士坦丁堡主教，其地位已经提升到了安提、耶路撒冷和亚历山大主教之上。
So the links with Rome are still very important and this is something that that does kind of haunt people in constantinople the sense that they have they've lost a kind of vital part of what it is to be roman so let's talk about the should we talk about the characters our principles so let's start with since we've framed this through Theodora, I should say, Tom, we've been very remiss, haven't we, in not pointing out to our listeners, some of whom I think are new because we've accumulated new listeners in recent days, that Theodora is actually the reigning champion of historical Love Island. She is, yes. Yes, she absolutely is. Which was a much-fated show, a much-fated historical reality show that we did, in which she triumphed
所以与罗马的联系依然非常重要，这种感觉一直萦绕在君士坦丁堡人们的心头——他们觉得自己失去了身为罗马人至关重要的一部分。那么，我们来谈谈……我们应该谈谈我们的人物，即我们的主角。既然我们是通过西奥多拉来铺陈这个故事的，我得说，汤姆，我们太失职了，对吧？我们竟然没有向听众——其中一些人我想是新听众，因为我们最近几天积累了许多新听众——指出，西奥多拉实际上是历史版“恋爱岛”（Love Island）的卫冕冠军。她的确是，是的。是的，她绝对是。这是一个备受关注的节目，一个我们做过的好评如潮的历史真人秀节目，她在节目中获胜了，
along with former Prime Minister, three-time Prime Minister. In the 30s? In the 20s, 20s and 30s, Stanley Baldwin. They made a lovely couple. Improbable. Improbable, but very successful. Much liked by the fans. Yes. And if you want to find out more about that, you should go to our
搭档是前首相、三任首相。在30年代？在20年代，20年代和30年代的斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）。他们是一对可爱的情侣。不太可能的一对。不太可能，但非常成功。深受粉丝喜爱。是的。如果你想了解更多关于这方面的内容，应该去收听我们的
historical Love Island episode. But Dominic, of course, also Theodora's husband, Justinian, of course, was the theme of our previous episode that we did with Karl Harper on the collapse of the Roman Empire and the impact that pathogens had on it. And in that episode, when we talked about the Justinianic plague, Justinian is the Justinian as in the Justinianic plague. Exactly. And he's a great character too, actually, Tom. He is a tremendously impressive character. Or is he, as we will discuss.
历史版“恋爱岛”那一期。不过多米尼克，当然，西奥多拉的丈夫查士丁尼，也是我们之前和凯尔·哈珀（Kyle Harper）一起做的那期关于罗马帝国崩溃以及病原体对它影响的节目的主题。在那期节目中，当我们谈到查士丁尼瘟疫时，那个查士丁尼就是指查士丁尼瘟疫里的查士丁尼。正是如此。他也是个了不起的人物，汤姆。他是一个极其令人印象深刻的人物。或者说，正如我们接下来要讨论的，真的是这样吗？
So let's start with, should we start with Theodora? So Theodora, she is born about, we don't know exactly, about 500, I think that's fair to say, isn't it, Tom? Yeah, roughly that, yeah. And again, we don't know, well, because she's from a lowly background, we're not entirely sure, I think that's fair to say, isn't it Tom? Yeah, roughly that, yeah. And again, we don't know. Well, because she's from a lowly background, we're not entirely sure, I think, of her sort of, as it were, her ethnic ancestry. So some people said she was from Cyprus. Some people said she was from Syria.
所以让我们从……我们应该从西奥多拉开始吗？那么西奥多拉，她出生于大约——我们虽然不知道确切时间，但大约在500年左右，我想这么说挺公正的吧，汤姆？是的，差不多那个时候。同样，我们不知道……由于她出身卑微，我们其实不太确定——我想这样说也算客观吧，汤姆？是的，差不多那个时候。同样，我们不知道。由于她出身卑微，我们并不完全确定，她的某种……可以说是她的族裔血统。所以有人说她来自塞浦路斯。有人说她来自叙利亚。
But we do know that she grew up in the city, in Constantinople, because her father, I believe, was a bear keeper. He was, yeah. And he's a bear keeper for one of the two main rival teams in the Hippodrome. Yeah. So this is, what, Manchester City, Manchester United? Yeah, but it's bigger than that. It's much bigger than that. Liverpool, Everton.
但我们确实知道她是在这座城市里长大的，在君士坦丁堡，因为她的父亲，我相信，是一名看熊人。他确实是的。他是赛马场两个主要敌对阵营之一的看熊人。是的。所以这相当于，什么？曼城对曼联？对，但比那还要宏大。规模大得多。利物浦对埃弗顿。
The Greens and the Blues. The Greens and the Blues. And they hate each other. The supporters hate each other. But they're not just... So people often... I mean mean it's one thing that people who don't know much about constantinople know about constantinople is they have these mad circus sort of chariot racing factions and teams but they're more than sports teams aren't they they're kind of militias they're almost yeah they're not they're kind of clubs they're yeah and they take sides in kind of
绿党和蓝党。绿党和蓝党。他们视彼此为死敌。支持者们恨之入骨。但他们不仅仅是……所以人们常常……我的意思是，不太了解君士坦丁堡的人对君士坦丁堡仅有的了解之一，就是他们有这些疯狂的马车赛派系和车队，但他们不仅仅是体育迷，对吧？他们有点像民兵组织。几乎是的。他们不只是……他们更像是俱乐部，对吧？而且他们在
theological arguments, which I think is something that we very much miss from contemporary sport. Yeah, you don't get that with fans of West Bromwich Albion, do you? They are. Well, they're potential paramilitaries. Yeah. So, you know, I mean, obviously, if you've got huge gangs of ultras, I mean, that's the kind of standing temptation, aren't they?
神学争论中也会选边站，我认为这是当代体育中非常缺失的一点。是的，你在西布朗维奇（West Bromwich Albion）的球迷身上可看不到这一点。他们确实……嗯，他们是潜在的准军事组织。所以，你知道，很显然，如果你拥有庞大的极端球迷帮派（ultras），我的意思是，这是一种常有的诱惑，不是吗？
Yeah. You kind of get that slightly in Russia, don't you, yeah in russia you got it in yugoslavia in the 1990s um fans of dino mozagreb or red star belgrade yeah absolutely i mean that's not unknown at all i mean to a degree perhaps just you know a little bit in glasgow celtic rangers yeah i mean slight kind of you know there's because because there you have a kind of sectarian divide people taking positions i mean you know they're not arguing about transubstantiation or anything but you know there's a slight kind of theological edge there so that's maybe a kind of very faint distorted parallel so so anyway the the greens have their own bear i mean they obviously must
你有时会在俄罗斯看到这种现象，对吧？在俄罗斯有，在20世纪90年代的南斯拉夫也有——萨格勒布迪纳摩或贝尔格莱德红星的球迷。绝对的，这并不罕见。在某种程度上，也许在格拉斯哥的凯尔特人和流浪者队身上也能看到一点，对吧？——也就是有那么一点……因为在那里存在一种宗派分歧，人们会表明立场。我的意思是，他们不是在争论“圣体变容”什么的，但你知道，那里确实带有一点神学色彩，所以这也许是一个非常微弱、变形的平行对比。不管怎样，绿党有他们自己的熊，他们显然必须
put on shows and they both have bears yes Yes. I mean, they must have multiple animals, I assume. And Theodore's father, who I think is called Acacius, he is a bear keeper, isn't he? And we don't know her mother's name. Her mother probably, again, a performer, an acrobat, a dancer. What do you think, Tom? I think if you kind of imagine the Super Bowl crossed with a kind of very high class strip club. You probably have some idea of what's going on in the kind of the intervals between the races. Yeah. Because after each race, invariably people will crash.
进行表演，而且双方都有熊，是的。我的意思是，他们一定养了多种动物，我猜。西奥多拉的父亲——我想他叫阿卡修斯（Acacius），他是一名看熊人，对吧？我们不知道她母亲的名字。她母亲可能也是一名表演者、杂技演员、舞者。你觉得呢，汤姆？我想如果你把“超级碗”（Super Bowl）和某种非常高级的脱衣舞俱乐部结合起来，你大概就能想象出比赛间隙里正在发生什么了。因为每场比赛结束后，难免会有人发生碰撞，
You know, bits of body will have to be removed from the sand will have to be swept up. Everything has to be prepared. And often you're having kind of 20 or so races in a day. So they need entertainment because you've got what kind of 50 000 people it because this is a vast hippodrome the original one that was built but back in the early third century wasn't large enough um so it kind of sticks off the hill on which it's been built and it's held up on kind of great concrete props so it's a it's an extraordinary structure and it has this this great kind of spine running down the middle that's decorated with an obelisk and statues and and actually um the the famous trophy that the greeks
你知道，身体的某些部分必须从沙地上清理出去，沙子必须被打扫干净。一切都需要重新准备。通常一天要进行大约20场左右的比赛。所以他们需要娱乐，因为现场大概有——怎么也有5万人左右，因为这是一个巨大的赛马场。早期在3世纪初建造的那个并不够大，所以它一部分延伸到了建造它的山丘之外，靠着巨大的混凝土支柱支撑着——这是一个非凡的建筑结构，中间有一条延伸的“脊柱”（spine），用方尖碑和雕像装饰着。实际上，当年希腊人在德尔菲（Delphi）
set up in delphi and after the defeat of the persians back in the fifth century bc and which is still there um so an extraordinary place and this is what um theodora her two sisters her mother her father they are making their living from this so they're kind of born into the entertainments that are laid on in between the races well she appears as a child doesn't she she appears in burlesques and comedies and so it you know she's it's like being born into a circus family, but sort of turned up to a thousand. But her father dies, doesn't he, when she's quite young. Yeah. And her mother marries again, I think.
为纪念公元前5世纪击败波斯人而设立的著名奖杯至今仍在那里——所以这是一个非凡的地方。而这就是西奥多拉、她的两个姐妹、她的母亲和父亲赖以谋生的环境；所以他们基本上是生于赛马场间隙的各种娱乐表演之中。她在很小的时候就登台了，不是吗？她出现在滑稽剧和喜剧中，所以这……这就好像生在一个马戏团家庭，只不过被放大了上千倍。但她的父亲在她很小的时候就去世了，对吧？是的，她的母亲又结婚了，我想。
So they're with the Greens. Yeah. And her mother goes to see the Greens and says, I've married again. And she takes her children with her, I think, Theodore among them. She goes to see the Greens and she said, the bosses of the Greens, she says, I've married again.
所以他们跟着绿党。是的。她的母亲去找绿党的人说：“我改嫁了。”我想她带着孩子们，其中也包括西奥多拉。她去见绿党，对绿党的老板说：“我改嫁了。”
That bear keeper job, can my new husband have the bear keeper job? And the Greens say, no, we've given it to someone else. And she is so outraged that the whole family switch allegiances. Well, she does it in public. So she brings the children trying to tug the heartstrings of the crowd before where the um you know the leaders of the greens are and they turn her down publicly and so that the leaders of the blues then say oh we'll we'll give you the job yeah so so they switch and um this is quite important for the story because justinian before he becomes emperor is a big partisan of the blues
“那个看熊人的工作，能给我现任的丈夫吗？”绿党说：“不行，我们已经把这工作给别人了。”她气愤至极，导致整个家族直接倒戈。嗯，她是当众这么做的。所以她带着孩子们试图博取人群的同情，就在绿党领袖们面前，而绿党当众拒绝了她。于是蓝党的领袖们便说：“哦，那这个工作交给我们吧。”所以他们倒戈了。
so he is yes that means that from this point on, Theodora and Justinian are supporting the same team. And so Theodora has to make her way in the world. Her mother, you know, they've got this link with the a dancer, an acrobat, a comedian, that in the world of Constantinople in the early 6th century, that blurs quite imperceptibly into the world, as you said, of being a stripper or indeed of being a courtesan. Because that effectively, I guess, is what she probably was when she was in her late teens, maybe.
这对故事的发展非常重要，因为查士丁尼在成为皇帝之前，是蓝党的狂热支持者。他确实是。这意味着从这一刻起，西奥多拉和查士丁尼支持的是同一个阵营。因此，西奥多拉必须在世上闯荡。她的母亲……她们有这样的背景——舞者、杂技演员、喜剧演员，在公元6世纪初的君士坦丁堡，这些身份与我们刚才提到的钢管舞女或交际花的身份之间，界限变得相当模糊。因为我猜，这基本上就是她十几岁快成年时可能从事的行业。
So this is something that Constantinople, again, has inherited from Rome, who viewed actors as the lowest of the low, so ranked alongside prostitutes. And as you say, the boundary between prostitute and actress was often very narrow. And so Constantinople has inherited that prejudice but it's now also a christian city in which acting burlesques and prostitution are all condemned for christian reasons right so there's there's uh there's lots of reasons why theodora might get you know public condemnations um and why in due course uh she betters herself by essentially turning her back on the on the theater and on the on the hippodrome because she gets a patron doesn't she yeah oh the civil
所以这是君士坦丁堡从罗马那里继承来的另一个传统：罗马视演员为社会底层的最低端，与妓女同列。正如你所说，妓女和女演员之间的界限往往非常狭窄。因此，君士坦丁堡继承了这种偏见，但它同时也是一座基督教城市，在这里，演艺、滑稽剧和卖淫都因基督教的原因受到谴责。因此，西奥多拉遭到公众谴责的理由有很多，这也是为什么假以时日，她通过基本上背叛了剧院和赛马场的生活来提升自己的社会地位，因为她找到了一个赞助人，不是吗？是的，那个去利比亚当总督的公务员家伙——
servant guy who goes off to govern Libya yeah Hekebalus and he's a bit of a brute so he beats her yeah and so she runs away leaves him and goes to Alexandria where she seems to have had a kind of religious experience so so that everybody Christian, and they take it incredibly seriously. I mean, well, not everyone is Christian. Well, who's not Christian? Well, we'll come to this, but say there are Platonists in Athens, say, still at this point. Not many people. But they are still very much a part of the fabric of it. But the details of Christian doctrine are a matter of enormous political and cultural significance.
海克巴卢斯（Hekebalus），他有点像个蛮夫，经常虐待她，所以她逃跑了，离开了他，去了亚历山大港，在那里她似乎经历了一种宗教体验——所以每个人都是基督徒，而且他们对此极其严肃。嗯，并不是每个人都是基督徒。那么谁不是基督徒？嗯，我们待会儿会聊到这个，比如此时雅典还有柏拉图主义者。虽然人数不多，但他们确实仍然是社会结构的一部分。不过基督教教义的细节具有极其重大的政治和文化意义。
And the arguments about those details, when she ends up, she's been in Constantinople, she goes to Alexandria. She is going to a part of the empire that many people in the capital regard as heretical, don't they? Because the people in Alexandria,andria it's alexandra is a hotbed of something called monophysitism should we at this point take a break before everyone runs for terror should we have a break and then when we come back i think we should um roll up our sleeves and just we won't go into it in huge detail but we just need to explain what the what the point of issue is and it's actually very exciting, Tom. It is exciting. I think actually, I think people will, it's a cliffhanger. I've just, I've become so kind of, you know, sensitive to you complaining when we talk
而当她最终身处君士坦丁堡、随后又前往亚历山大港时，关于这些细节的争论，使她来到了一个被首都许多人视为异端的帝国部分，不是吗？因为亚历山大港的人们……亚历山大港是被称为“基督一性论”（Monophysitism）的温床。我们是不是应该在这个时候休息一下，免得大家吓得落荒而逃？我们休息一下，等回来后，我想我们应该卷起袖子——虽然不会深入探讨所有细节，但我们确实需要解释一下争议的焦点在哪里。其实这非常激动人心，汤姆。确实很激动人心。我想实际上，大家会觉得这像个悬念。我刚才对你抱怨我们谈论基督教时的敏感度——
about Christianity that... Do you know, I should tell the listeners this, this is the only time in recorded history where when we were discussing this episode, I said to Tom, come on, get stuck into it, do it properly. And he was, he was a little And he was a little bit nervous. So come back after the break to see Tom talking about the nature of Christ. See you in a minute. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde.
你知道，我应该告诉听众们：这是录音史上绝无仅有的一次，当我们讨论这一集时，我对汤姆说：“来吧，深入进去，好好讲讲。”而他当时……他稍微有点紧张。所以，休息过后回来听汤姆讲解基督的本质吧。一会儿见。拜拜。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐至死》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告干扰的收听体验、加更节目、
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now, you may remember that the first half of this episode began with an extraordinary reading from Tom Holland about the special brand of gymnastics performed by the Empress Theodora when she was a girl.
想要提前收听直播门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。现在，大家可能还记得，这集的前半部分开始于汤姆·霍兰对狄奥多拉皇后少女时代所表演的特殊体操进行的精彩宣读。
Now, Tom will be producing his own special brand of gymnastics as he is going to explain the nature of the monophysite heresy. A very exciting subject. It's actually a bloodstained subject. So it's much more interesting than sceptics might think. So Tom, what on earth is going on? So probably one of the things that people know about Byzantium, and it's been a kind of subject of mockery again, ever since the time of Edward Gibbon is that the the empire and the church is endlessly debating the nature of Christ. So this happens right from the beginning. So under Constantine, there are debates about whether whether the son, Jesus, you know, whether Christ is a part of God, whether the son is is kind of co-eternal with the father all this kind of stuff and that gets resolved and they decide basically that yes uh that the father son and and spirit are
接下来，汤姆将展示他自己特有的“体操”，因为他将解释一性论异端的本质。这是一个非常令人兴奋的主题。实际上，这是一个血腥的主题。所以它比怀疑论者想象的要有趣得多。那么，汤姆，这到底是怎么回事？所以，人们对拜占庭的了解之一，自爱德华·吉本时代以来，它再次成为嘲笑的对象，那就是帝国和教会对基督的本质进行了无休止的辩论。所以这种情况从一开始就发生了。所以在君士坦丁统治时期，人们争论圣子耶稣，你知道，基督是否是上帝的一部分，圣子是否与圣父同永恒，所有这些事情，最终都得到了解决，他们基本上决定，是的，呃，圣父、圣子和圣灵是
all kind of part of a whole um this is very precise but by the by the fifth century there's a new controversy and that is basically uh so theologians have decided that christ the figure of jesus is both human and divine so he has two natures he has his divine nature and he has his human nature and the question then is what is the relationship of these two natures yeah yeah so basically you boil it down to thinking like this so is it like gin and tonic? So you have your gin, let's say that's the divine, and you have your tonic, that's the human, and you mix them up in a glass and they become indivisible.
都算是整体的一部分，嗯，这非常精确，但到了五世纪，出现了一种新的争议，那就是，呃——神学家们已经决定，基督，耶稣这个人物，既有人性又有神性；所以他有两种本质，他有神性，也有人性，然后问题就是这两种本质的关系是什么。对，对——所以基本上你可以把它归结为这样思考：就像金酒加汤力水吗？比如你有金酒，我们假设那是神性，然后你有汤力水，那是人性，你把它们混在一个杯子里，它们就密不可分了。
Yeah. Or are they like olive oil and water? They don't mix. And they don't mix. No. And so this becomes the kind of the great great dividing line i mean we could sort of get bogged down in all this couldn't we in the in the details of it but i suppose the essence of it is that am i right in thinking there was a there was a ecumenical
是啊。或者它们像橄榄油和水？它们不混合。而且它们不混合。不。于是这就成了那条伟大而又巨大的分界线——我的意思是，我们可能会陷入这一切之中，不是吗？陷入其中的细节，但我认为其精髓在于，我是不是觉得曾经有过一次大公会议——
council that's a big a big meeting of church bigwigs in 451 bishops in chalcedon which is now but again part of istanbul but on the Asian side. Yeah. And they basically hammered out what they thought was the formula. And then some people didn't like it. Yeah. So the formulation that they arrive at Chalcedon, which is still upheld by pretty much the Orthodox, the Catholics, Protestants, I mean, they all uphold it, is that you have one and the same
那是一次教会显贵的大聚会，在451年的迦克敦举行，迦克敦现在也是伊斯坦布尔的一部分，但在亚洲那一侧。对。他们基本上敲定了他们认为是公式的东西。然后有些人不喜欢它。对。所以在迦克敦达成的表述，直到今天基本上仍被东正教、天主教、新教所支持——我的意思是，他们都支持这一点——那就是你拥有同一个
son, our Lord Jesus Christ, the same perfect in Godhead and also perfect in manhood, truly God and truly man. So in other words, the oil and the water, they're both equally important. They haven't mixed to create what in Greek is monophysis, a single, a soul nature. I told you it would be tom's special brand of gymnastics and it is but after chalcedon there are still people who who are very keen on the idea that this single nature is what christ is all about so they come to be called monophysites so as far as i can tell from my reading of this this is not just a sort of doctrinal theological issue. It's also an issue about power and regions and so on. Everything is.
圣子，我们的主耶稣基督，他在神性上完美，在人性上也完美，是真正的上帝，也是真正的人。换句话说，油和水，它们同样重要。它们没有融合创造出希腊语中的 monophysis，即单一的、唯一的本质。我告诉过你这会是汤姆式的特殊体操，确实如此。但在迦克敦会议之后，仍然有些人非常热衷于这种单一本质就是基督的全部的思想，所以他们被称为“一性论者”。因此，据我所读到的来看，这不仅仅是一个教义上的神学问题。这也是一个关于权力、地区等的问题。一切都是。
Yeah, of course. So you've got, as it were, the, in inverted commas, orthodox view, which is the view held in Constantinople, and it's associated, I suppose, with the state, with the emperor, and with a sort of central authority. And then you have this heresy, as it's called, which is monophysitism. And that's stronger in places like Alexandria
是的，当然。所以你拥有，可以说是，打上引号的“正统”观点，也就是君士坦丁堡持有的观点，它被认为与国家、皇帝以及某种中央集权有关。然后你有了这种所谓的“异端”，也就是一性论。在亚历山大里亚等地它更为强大。
and bits of Syria and so on. So in other words, in Egypt, North Africa, in places that maybe would resist very strong central control and being bossed around by the capital. So it's a capital versus provincial thing to some extent, isn't it? Well, I mean, you mentioned Alexandria, which is the second city so of the empire it always has been ever since um the defeat of cleopatra uh it's like constantinople a very
以及叙利亚的一些地方等等。换句话说，在埃及、北非，在那些可能会抵制非常强硬的中央控制、不愿被首都颐指气使的地方。所以从某种程度上说，这是首都与省份的问题，不是吗？嗯，我的意思是，你提到了亚历山大里亚，它是帝国的第二大城市，自从克利奥帕特拉战败以来一直如此，它和君士坦丁堡一样，是一座非常
turbulent city very proud of its dignity and status and in a way the kind of the tensions between chalcedonian and monophysite christians become a way for alexandria to kind of proclaim its its um its distinctiveness yeah and so when theodora turns up there she comes under the wing of the patriarch timothy and she she she becomes a very devout monophysite rather i suppose rather in the manner, and I think that this is kind of an important part of her appeal to Christians in the long run, rather like the way that Mary Magdalene is coming to be portrayed as a kind of repentant prostitute. Even if there is nothing in the Gospels themselves that sustains that, the idea that someone who has turned to Christ, whose background perhaps
动荡的城市，为其尊严和地位感到非常骄傲。从某种程度上说，迦克敦派和一性论基督徒之间的紧张关系，成了亚历山大里亚宣示其独特性的一种方式。是的，所以当狄奥多拉出现在那里时，她来到了大主教蒂莫西的羽翼之下，她成了一个非常虔诚的一性论者，我想，这在某种程度上是她对长期以来的基督徒产生吸引力的重要部分，很像抹大拉的马利亚被描绘成一个悔罪的妓女的那种方式。即使福音书本身没有任何内容支持这一点，那种转向基督的人、其背景也许
is not all it could have been, in a way is a kind of greater catch. Yeah, of course. But that's part of Theodore's enduring appeal. I mean, in a way you could argue, Tom, that's one of the reasons we're doing this podcast at all, is because that archetype of the sort of- The repentant whore. Yeah. The woman who was once terribly licentious but has now repented and become incredibly good and incredibly impressive. I mean, that runs through Western culture, doesn't it? Yeah.
并非无可挑剔的人，在某种程度上是一种更大的“收获”。是的，当然。但那是狄奥多拉持久魅力的一部分。我的意思是，从某种程度上你可以辩称，汤姆，这就是我们做这个播客的原因之一，因为那种原型——悔罪的妓女。是的。那个曾经非常放荡但现在已经忏悔并变得无比善良和令人印象深刻的女人。我的意思是，这贯穿了西方文化，不是吗？是的。
So she must have returned, we don't know exactly when, I think, to Constantinople at the end of her teens or in her very early 20s. Yeah. And there at some point that we don't know, again, she's obviously still a great catch. I mean, she's still young. And she meets an older man who is a real rising star whose name is, well, his original name
所以她一定回到了君士坦丁堡——我们不知道确切时间，我想是在她十几岁快结束或二十岁出头的时候。是的。然后在那里的某个时刻，我们同样不知道，她显然仍然是一个极好的选择。我的意思是，她还很年轻。她遇到了一位年长的、真正的后起之星，他的名字是，嗯，他原来的名字
is Flavius Petrus Sabartius. But now he calls himself Justinian. Because he's been adopted by a guy called Justin who just happens to be the emperor just happens to be the emperor exactly so the empire when theodora was born the emperor was a man called anastasius yes who had two interesting distinction his eyes were different colors yes one was black and one was blue wasn't yeah a black eye and he was also very bald very bald i mean can he be very bald?
是弗拉维乌斯·彼得鲁斯·萨巴蒂乌斯。但现在他叫自己查士丁尼。因为他被一个叫查士丁的人收养了，而这个人刚好是皇帝——刚好是皇帝，没错。所以当狄奥多拉出生时，帝国的皇帝是一个叫阿纳斯塔修斯的人，是的，他有两个有趣的特征：他的眼睛颜色不同，是的，一只黑，一只蓝，对吧？一只黑眼，而且他非常秃，非常秃——我的意思是，他能非常秃吗？
I think he, well, very bald because he gets praised by poets who are looking to flatter him. Right. About his baldness. Yes, because they hail him. They say of his forehead that it gleams like silver. So he's a bolder man than Stanley Tucci, who's very bald, but he's even bolder. But I think his forehead has this kind of this. Tremendous- This tremendous glow. This glow.
我认为他，嗯，非常秃，因为他受到了试图奉承他的诗人们的赞美。对。赞美他的秃顶。是的，因为他们赞美他。他们说他的额头像银子一样闪闪发光。所以他比斯坦利·图齐还要秃，斯坦利·图齐就很秃，但他更秃。但我认为他的额头有这种——巨大的——这种巨大的光芒。这种光芒。
And he is basically a kind of, he's a bureaucrat. He's a civil servant who's been, he's kind of stepped up because there's a gap, there's a vacancy. And the fact that he can be praised for having a gleaming forehead, it's a reflection, not just on his boldness, but also the fact that he's an absolute whiz at accountancy. And the treasury has been a bit depleted. Anastasius' great contribution,
他基本上是一种，他是一个官僚。他是一个公务员，由于有一个空缺，有一个职位空缺，他得到了提拔。他能因为拥有发光的额头而受到赞美，这不仅反映了他的秃顶，也反映了他绝对是个会计奇才。国库已经有点枯竭了。阿纳斯塔修斯的伟大贡献，
rather than going out and kind of leading campaigns, he stays in the palace, he crunches numbers, he counts beans, and he sets the Roman currency, the Byzantine currency, on a tremendously strong new footing. So the solidus, as it's called, it is solid. It's a massively strong currency made of gold. And basically, this will be the kind of the underpinning for Byzantine financial strength for centuries and centuries to come. An immensely bold emperor with a very, very solid solidus is what you're saying. But anyway, I think it's good to talk about Anastasius because that gives the lie to any lingering ideas that this is a sort of decadent, shambolic, incompetent, excessively corrupt, all of these kinds of things that have been thrown at the Eastern Roman Empire. This is a confident, relatively stable state, isn't it? Dominating the Eastern Mediterranean. relatively stable state isn't it dominating the eastern mediterranean it's based so basically
与其说是出去领导战役，不如说他呆在皇宫里，计算数字，盘点豆子，并将罗马货币、拜占庭货币建立在一个极其坚实的新基础上。所以所谓的苏勒地斯金币，它是坚固的。它是由黄金制成的极其坚强的货币。基本上，这将成为未来几个世纪拜占庭财政实力的基础。你的意思是，这是一个非常秃的皇帝，有着非常非常坚固的苏勒地斯金币。不过，无论如何，我觉得讨论阿纳斯塔修斯是件好事，因为这打破了任何挥之不去的想法，即这是一个衰落的、混乱的、无能的、过度腐败的政权——所有这些被强加给东罗马帝国的标签。这是一个自信、相对稳定的国家，不是吗？统治着东地中海。相对稳定的国家，不是吗？统治着东地中海。它基于——所以基本上
it's run by militarized accountants yes of whom anastasius is the absolute exemplar so kind of civil servants who are working in the great palace are kind of recruited into a non-existent legion and they they have swagger sticks they they wear gold, they wear purple, they wear tremendous belts, these military belts that descend from the legionary tradition that become the emblem of the bureaucrat. constantine quite a kind of austere basis by this point it's a kind of cross between gorman garst and the office it's it's a huge kind of great warren of passageways many different floors or you know they even have a riding school in the middle of it i mean this is basically like 10 downing street tom i mean yeah but on a much much larger scale yeah but you still have this kind of it's it's this kind of weird fusion of of you know the legionary inheritance but they're all accountants so so anastasius is absolutely the
它是由军事化的会计师管理的，是的，阿纳斯塔修斯就是其中的绝对典范。因此，在宏伟宫殿中工作的公务员被招募到一个并不存在的军团中，他们手持文明棍，穿着金色长袍，穿着紫色长袍，系着巨大的腰带——这些从军团传统传承下来的军事腰带成了官僚的象征。君士坦丁堡在这一点上有着相当朴素的基础，它是戈曼·加斯特（Gormenghast）与办公室的结合体——它是一个巨大的、错综复杂的通道网络，有许多不同的楼层，或者，你知道的，他们甚至在中间有一个骑术学校。我的意思是，这基本上就像唐宁街十号，汤姆——我的意思是，是的，但规模要大得多得多。是的，但你仍然有这种——这是一种奇怪的融合，你知道的，军团的传承，但他们全都是会计师——所以阿纳斯塔修斯绝对是
exemplar of that but of course anastasius needs to have guards you need to have bodyguards because as an as the emperor of course you do so they are also a feature of it and bodyguards usually are recruited from you know the the more barbarous reaches of the empire the balkans traditionally and so this guy arrives uh as a refugee from a barbarian invasion from uh from what is now scopier so scoopy it's called and this is justin i think his original name was istock yes he's a peasant stock isn isn't he? Possibly sort of Thracian ethnicity, we don't know. He's not, interestingly, Justin is not literate. So he has a stencil when he becomes,
这种风格的典范。但当然，阿纳斯塔修斯需要有卫兵，你需要保镖，因为作为皇帝，你当然需要；所以这也是其中的一个特征。保镖通常是从帝国的蛮族腹地招募的，传统上是巴尔干地区。所以这个家伙作为来自蛮族入侵的难民来到了这里，来自现在的斯科普里——所以被称为斯科普里。这就是查士丁，我想他原来的名字是伊斯特克。是的，他是农民出身，不是吗？可能是色雷斯血统，我们不知道。有趣的是，查士丁是不识字的。所以当他成为皇帝时，他有一个模板，
he has to do everything with a special sort of stencil. Anyway, we're jumping ahead. He's the commander of the guard, isn't he? Yeah. And basically, Anastasius has been emperor, what, from the end of the fifth century, and then he dies in 518, in the summer of 518. He's got no heir. And he doesn't have a son. Well, he does. I mean, potentially, he has three nephews. There's a very shambolic scene, isn't there, with his nephews. You know about the stuff with the couches? Remind me.
他必须用一种特殊的模板来做所有事情。不管怎样，我们言归正传。他是卫队指挥官，对吧？是的。基本上，阿纳斯塔修斯从五世纪末开始担任皇帝，然后在518年夏天去世。他没有继承人。他没有儿子。嗯，他确实有。从潜在意义上说，他有三个侄子。关于他的侄子们，有一个非常混乱的场景，不是吗？你知道关于沙发的事吗？提醒我一下。
So supposedly, I mean, this is one of these stories in the rest of his history in which he specialised that's almost certainly untrue. He decided that God would decide who would succeed him. So he wrote a note with the word regnum, and he put it under the cushions of one of the couches, and he decided that which of the nephews sat on this couch would succeed him because God would have chosen him. And they all came in, but they were great pals, all the nephews.
据说——我的意思是，这是《历史的其余部分》中那种他最擅长的故事之一，几乎可以肯定是不真实的。他决定由上帝来决定谁将继承他的王位。所以他写了一张便条，上面写着“regnum”（王权）这个词，把它塞进其中一张沙发的垫子下面，他决定哪位侄子坐在张沙发上，谁就会继承他的王位，因为那是上帝的选择。他们都进来了，但侄子们都是好朋友。
They all sat on the same couch. So they didn't. So it didn't work. Now, the other story is that he then said, oh, that was a terrible disaster. I shall pray to God. And he prays overnight and God gives him this vision and says, the man who comes into your bedchamber first tomorrow will be your heir. I mean, that's obviously a terrible way of
他们都坐在同一张沙发上。所以他们没有。所以这没用。现在，另一个说法是，他接着说，“哦，那是一场可怕的灾难。我要向上帝祈祷。”他祈祷了一夜，上帝给了他这个异象，并说：“明天第一个走进你寝室的人将是你的继承人。”我的意思是，这显然是一种可怕的决定方式。
deciding. The man who comes in as the commander of the guard, who is this Vulcan peasant. Justin. Called Justin. But there's another story, isn't there, that Justin basically bribes his way. Well, so when Anastasius dies, one of these three nephews, who's a very able man called Hypatius, is in command of the Roman forces on the eastern frontier against Persia. So that's a key military command. He's linked to the emperor and he has command of the armies, but he doesn't want it, basically. So he's happy to stand down. He's clearly not an ambitious man.
第一个进来的人是卫队指挥官，也就是这个巴尔干农民。查士丁。名叫查士丁。但还有另一个说法，不是吗？查士丁基本上是通过贿赂上位。嗯，当阿纳斯塔修斯去世时，这三个侄子中有一个非常有能力的人，名叫许帕提乌斯，他正在东部边境指挥罗马军队对抗波斯。所以那是一个关键的军事指挥权。他与皇帝有亲戚关系，并统帅军队，但他基本上不想要它。所以他乐意卸任。他显然不是一个有野心的人。
So you have this kind of squabble in the palace over who's going to do it. And one of the rival candidates gives Justin, who is commander of the guard, a whole load of gold and says, go out and bribe everyone to support me. So Justin goes out, he's got all this gold, and he thinks, well, I might as well bribe them to support me. And that's what he does.
所以在宫廷里，关于谁来担任这个职位，有一场争夺战。其中一个竞争候选人给担任卫队指挥官的查士丁一大堆黄金，并说：“出去贿赂所有人来支持我。”所以查士丁出去了，他带着这些黄金，他想：“嗯，我不如用它们来贿赂大家支持我好了。”这就是他所做的。
It's very House of Cards, isn't it? Yeah. It's very House of Cards. So he becomes emperor and he has this, he can't read and write, what he does it's very house of cards isn't it yeah very house of cards so he becomes emperor and he has this he can't read and write but he has this stencil with the word leggy on it in purple ink he's the only person allowed to use purple ink so he can sort of stencil his approval on all these documents but by this stage justin or i mean his name is flavius justinus he is in his mid-60s is he i think 70 even i mean he's pretty old so the real power behind him is his nephew who he definitely is literate yes who's almost certainly had an
这非常像《纸牌屋》，不是吗？是的。非常像《纸牌屋》。所以他成为了皇帝，他有这个——他不会读写，这非常像《纸牌屋》，不是吗？是的，非常像《纸牌屋》。所以他成为了皇帝，他有这个——他不会读写，但他有一个印着紫色墨水“leggy”字样的模板，他是唯一被允许使用紫色墨水的人，所以他可以在所有这些文件上盖上他的批准。但到这个阶段，查士丁——或者说他的名字叫弗拉维乌斯·查士丁努斯——已经六十多岁了，是吗？我想甚至有70岁了。我的意思是，他相当老了。所以他背后的真正权力是他的侄子，他绝对是识字的，是的，他几乎肯定在
education in constantinople has come to sort of you know to to profit from his uncle's success in the guard and this is the person who calls himself very clearly very clever and quite serious tom he's a very very devout christian yeah he's also very very patriotic he wants to see the roman empire restored he has all kinds of plans he's impatient with justin who by this point if procopius is to be trusted is um is slightly losing it he's joe biden basically he's slightly joe biden well no i think i think even maybe even worse um but justinian has big big plans but he obviously needs to you know there's nothing guaranteeing the fact that he will succeed so you know he's he's a he's a bit like a kind of, you know, a prime minister or president in waiting, like a vice president or chancellor of the Exchequer or something.
君士坦丁堡接受过教育，并从他叔叔在卫队的成功中获益。这就是那个自称——非常聪明而且相当严肃的汤姆，他是一个非常非常虔诚的基督徒。是的，他也非常非常爱国。他希望看到罗马帝国恢复昔日的荣光。他有着各种各样的计划，他对外表上如果普罗科匹乌斯可信的话、已经有点神志不清的查士丁感到不耐烦。他基本上就是乔·拜登，他有点像乔·拜登——哦不，我觉得——甚至可能更糟。但查士丁尼有宏伟的计划，但他显然需要——你知道的，没有什么能保证他一定会成功，所以，你知道的，他有点像一个候任的首相或总统，就像副总统或财政大臣之类的。
Yeah. You know, he's running a campaign to make sure that he does it. And as part of that, you know, we mentioned before, he's a keen devotee of the blues in the Hippodrome. Yeah. And the blues are, there's a kind of a particular paramilitary wing who all wear mullets. Yes, I've heard about that. They're more than strange shirts that are very big, but they narrow at the end of their arms and their wrists. Weird.
是的。你知道的，他正在开展竞选活动，以确保自己能成功。作为其中的一部分，正如我们之前提到的，他是竞技场里“蓝党”的狂热崇拜者。是的。而蓝党有一支特殊的准军事翼，他们都留着鲻鱼头。是的，我听说过。他们穿着奇怪的衬衫，非常宽大，但在手臂和手腕末端变窄。真怪异。
So they look, they're kind of like Hephthalites, kind of Hunnic people who are busy attacking the Persians at this point so they're obviously very menacing and justinian employs them as a kind of paramilitary unit to essentially you know establish himself as the master of constantinople while justin is in the palace um and he is he's he's preparing for for the rule of the empire and this is when he meets theodora yeah there's a problem he He falls madly, madly in love with her. And even Procopius, there's not a breath in Procopius' assassination, literary assassination of Justinian Theodora, that they were ever anything other than utterly devoted to each other. But there's a problem because she comes from the kind of background that is legally unacceptable. It's not just in for a dig. It's positively illegal. For somebody of senatorial rank, which Justin is,
所以他们看起来，有点像嚈哒人，那种当时正忙着攻击波斯的匈人，所以他们显然非常具有威胁性，查士丁尼把他们当作一支准军事部队来使用，本质上是为了（当查士丁在宫里时）确立自己作为君士坦丁堡主人的地位。嗯，他正在为统治帝国做准备，正是在这个时候，他遇到了狄奥多拉。是的，有个问题。他疯狂地、疯狂地爱上了她。甚至在普罗科匹乌斯对查士丁尼和狄奥多拉的文学暗杀中，也没有一丝一毫的迹象表明他们彼此不是全心全意地相爱。但有个问题，因为她的背景在法律上是不可接受的。不仅仅是不体面，它是绝对非法的。对于具有元老阶层身份的人来说——查士丁是，
sorry, which Justinian is, Justinian was also made consul, I think, in 521. So he's had every office bar the imperial title that you could have, and he just is not allowed to marry her. And there's a further complication, which is that even though Justin is happy to kind of wangle the law and basically kind of fix it so that if you're a repentant actress, which I think is a wonderful concept, a repentant actress or prostitute, then the marriage is fine. There's a further complication because Justin's wife,
抱歉，查士丁尼是——查士丁尼也在521年左右被任命为执事。所以除了帝王称号之外，他拥有你可以拥有的一切职位，而他就是不被允许娶她。还有一个更复杂的情况，那就是尽管查士丁很高兴能够扭曲法律，并基本上将其修复为：如果你是一个悔罪的女演员——我认为“悔罪的女演员或妓女”是一个绝妙的概念——那么这桩婚姻就没问题了。还有一个更复杂的情况，那就是查士丁的妻子，
again, if Procopius is to be trusted, was herself a slave. She had originally been a slave, a concubine. So her name originally was Lupicina. And lupa in Latin means a she-wolf, but it also meant a prostitute. So whether this is just Procopius being muckraking or whether that's true, we don't know. But clearly she came from, again, quite an infradig background. She has taken on, I think, the very telling name of Euphemia, which means well-spoken. So maybe... Very Pygmalion there, Tom.
同样，如果普罗科匹乌斯可信的话，她本人曾是一名奴隶。她最初是一名奴隶、一个妾。所以她最初的名字叫卢琵娜（Lupicina）。拉丁语中的“lupa”意思是母狼，但它也指妓女。所以这究竟是普罗科匹乌斯在捕风捉影还是确有其事，我们不得而知。但很显然，她的背景同样相当不体面。我想她采用了那个非常说明问题的名字——欧费米娅（Euphemia），意思是“善于言辞的”。所以也许……非常有《窈窕淑女》的感觉，汤姆。
Yeah, expressive of a certain kind of social anxiety. So basically, the last thing that Euphemia wants is to have this kind of showgirl as a yeah as a daughter-in-law because that will then direct attention to her own kind of awkward background so so she dies fortunately just in the nick of time so justinian and theodore are able to get married um and then justin dies and justinian is able to become emperor. And Theodora is given a remarkable degree of dignity. I mean, so Augusta, female of Augustus, this is the title of the empress. But Theodora is joined with Justinian in all kinds of salutations and formulae across the emperor. And he makes it absolutely clear that Theodora is going to rule
是的，表达了某种社会焦虑。所以基本上，欧费米娅最不想看到的就是让这样一个歌女作为儿媳妇，因为那会把人们的注意力引向她自己那种尴尬的背景。所以，谢天谢地，她在千钧一发之际去世了，因此查士丁尼和狄奥多拉得以结婚，然后查士丁去世了，查士丁尼得以成为皇帝。而狄奥多拉被赋予了非凡的尊严。我的意思是，奥古斯塔（Augusta），奥古斯都的女性形式，这是皇后的称号。但狄奥多拉在整个帝国的各种祝辞和公式中都与查士丁尼并列。他明确表示狄奥多拉将与他
alongside him so this is the year 527 the spring of 527 i think the first of april uh justinian is in his mid-40s 45 or so uh theodora is still in her late 20s about 20s probably about 27 or so and they are they now have the reins of power in what is still the mediterranean's most glittering most potent most glamorous and prestigious state don't they and justinian has all these ideas about how he's going to plan he's going to rebuild the glory of rome he's going to change he's going to transform the map of europe and well tom we've been talking for almost 50 minutes um and i think the what happens next which is tremendously exciting which involves riots uh disembodied heads um persians plague
陪伴在他身边，所以这是公元527年，527年的春天，我想是4月1日左右。查士丁尼正值四十岁出头，大约45岁左右；狄奥多拉还处于二十岁后期，大约二十多岁，可能27岁左右。他们如今掌握了权力，统治着当时依然是地中海地区最耀眼、最强大、最迷人、最负盛名的国家，对吧？查士丁尼有着各种各样的想法，关于他将如何规划、如何重塑罗马的辉煌、如何改变并重塑欧洲的地图。嗯，汤姆，我们已经聊了将近50分钟了，接下来要发生的事情极其精彩，其中包括暴乱、无头的尸体、波斯人、瘟疫……
every horseman of the apocalypse imaginable. Cathedrals. Yeah, building cathedrals. It's tremendously exciting stuff. And I think we should reconvene next time to find out what happens next. Let's do that. So let's do that. We shall see you next time. Bye-bye.
你能想象到的所有天启骑士。大教堂。是的，建造大教堂。这真是令人兴奋的内容。我认为我们应该下次再聚，看看接下来会发生什么。我们就这么办。那就这么办吧。我们下次再见。再见。
Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。